if you want to talk about a story that
is
pure evil i mean just pure unmitigated
immorality
it is this breaking story from vanity
fair that donald trump's
son-in-law jared kushner abandoned or
decided never to build the national
coronavirus testing program
because of the political calculation
that the coronavirus seemed to be
hitting
blue states and not red states and their
plan was
jared kushner's infinite wisdom was
let's just allow
it to run its course in in blue states
and will blame democratic governors this
is according to just a blockbuster new
report in vanity fair
as always with the trump administration
it's not just immorality it's also
incompetence because as we now
know the 20 top hot spots in the country
other than california are all in red
states so
not only was it immorality it was also a
miscalculation that this thing wasn't
going to spread to red
states now understand people died
because jared kushner said the virus is
in blue states we'll blame
democratic governors we don't have to
really build a testing program
we wondered early on well first of all
really early on we wondered why jared
kushner even had a role
in the government but okay i mean early
on in coronavirus we wondered why aren't
we building a testing program january
20th roughly within hours of each other
the united states and south korea got
our respective first
cases they immediately built a testing
program
as well as a tracing program as well as
fever clinics to isolate people
and south korea had one of the best
responses to coronavirus in the world
while still ranking higher than the
united states on the democracy index it
was not
some author wild authoritarian response
in the united states meanwhile we didn't
develop testing cases started to climb
confused messaging we don't want the who
test we're developing our own test but
our test development failed
meanwhile south korea had already
essentially gotten 90
of the control of the virus done and we
still didn't have testing and the rest
is history and we're about to have 160
000 people dead as a result of this
virus
eventually the trump administration
started claiming
we did have testing we have the most
tests in the world
we have the best tests in the world all
of those lies which we know to be lies
but there's still this kind of question
mark of what happened in the middle was
it merely trump
saying let's not do anything because i
don't believe this is going to become a
big deal
was there a calculation of some kind and
vanity fair's report
is very specific the kushner team which
had been put
shockingly i mean that the fact that
there was a kushner team running this
is a major insanity but the kushner team
decided
let's not do a national testing program
let's start with
this is in blue states this is the job
of governors
and then we will say this is the fault
of democratic governors look at how
great these republican governors did
now why did they do it well if you
looked at the map
in early april the virus was mostly in
blue states right the early hot spots
were
the new york city area including new
jersey california
boston was an early hot spot chicago
illinois and of course
the early hot spots were the places with
a whole bunch of direct flights
uh to china and to europe the early
places
uh that were sort of the sources of
infection for the world
so their idea was their gamble was they
thought it's going to stay in blue
states this is going to be a blue state
problem it was dumb to think that of
course if you understand
virology at all but that's not kushner's
area of expertise
and so they said let's just let it run
let's not develop a testing program
it'll be great politics because we'll be
able to say look at the failures of
these blue state governors
vote republican in november now it's
backfired in two ways
it's backfired politically it's
backfired from the point of view of
health which is of course
the real tragedy so first politically it
didn't stay in the blue states
and in fact this has been the major
issue that has destroyed donald trump's
approval in addition to the economy
which relates to the virus
and trump's handling of race issues
those are the big three
but the virus is the biggest on which
you see a large gap
between how do you believe trump handled
it and how do you believe
biden would have or will handle it so it
backfired politically
but more importantly because i care
about people
in terms of health not developing
a national testing program early led to
way more cases and way more deaths
period now
there's a lot of people continuing to
tweet stuff
like trump's not responsible for 160 000
deaths
of course not who's saying that the
point is
there are plenty of deaths which are
extra
unnecessary deaths due to the federal
government's handling
just look at just about any other
country very few countries have done
worse than us in terms of response
and so that delta the delta between this
is a global pandemic and some people
were going to die
and the number of deaths we have which
is now 160
one estimate says it could be 300 000 by
the end of the year i mean it's bad
we're getting up to 1500 deaths a day
again uh
some of that is attributable to i guess
now we've learned it's jared kushner
to blame for the non-testing decision
now
a more important question is what is the
number of people
that jared kushner's protocol
led to no longer be alive and i want to
be really clear right like
they decided to let it rip they decided
to let people die
because it was a political calculation
they miscalculated
it they thought it's going to kill
people in blue states and then we'll
blame democratic governors
that didn't work out so that's a
dystopian
dystopian nightmare but it's actually
even worse than that because
you know we there's that phrase hanlon's
razor it's an aphorism
never attribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity
earlier we thought that what was going
on was just stupidity or
primarily stupidity we are now learning
that it was malice this is actual
malice the allegation made in the vanity
fair article is
just let blue staters die they could
have done testing but they chose not to
shouldn't someone go to prison for this
people are asking about oh
you know should kushner resign resign he
should be in prison
and by the way he was never elected he
was never confirmed
he is certainly unqualified to even be
in this position
and he made the decision
to allow people to die for a
miscalculated political gain
now we've talked about like a little kid
trump deserves a consequence for what
he's done
the consequence is being voted out in
november because nothing else is going
to happen
jared kushner is also up on that list of
deserving
a consequence but i really want to be
clear here this also is on trump
one of the maybe misguided reactions
to what we've learned about jared
kushner here is
kushner is solely to blame trump picked
kushner
and to some degree the buck stops with
trump right i mean trump all
of obama's presidency was tweeting time
after time after time
the buck stops with obama so the buck
has to stop with
trump here as well i hope people are are
understanding that
so this is another scandal that in the
midst of
a dozen others is getting one percent of
the attention that it deserves
what happened to russian bounties i
don't know what happened to the new
health care plan that donald trump
claimed was going to be signed into law
yesterday
just nothing i guess it's every single
day
and it has to stop and this is i mean
this is now
a type of evil that goes far beyond
incompetence and
i i subscribe to hanlon's razor much of
what we've seen during the trump
administration
has not actually been malice it's been
indifference
it's been maybe negligence but it's been
led by incompetence
this is now a very specific allegation
of not incompetence but
actual malice and they must suffer the
consequences we're never getting back
the people that died as a result of
jared saying
it's mostly in blue states let's let it
rip instead of developing testing
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience
25 off your first order
this has been a game changer for me this
is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors i
have blood orange which i love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize when we're
dehydrated a lot of the time and it's
become a really
a great part of my daily routine if i'm
under hydrated
i'm affected physically i'm affected
mentally
and i think you never fully understand
this until you use hydrant for the first
time
i get a great uh boost of energy when
i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets twenty five
percent off your first order
when you go to drink hydrant dot com
slash
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video